all I can remember is not a great craft
service which is how I judge every
production and the smell on set was so
repugnant it felt like a very very small
gym but we weren't working out and I
don't know what that smell was hi I'm
Adam Devine and these are my iconic
characters mail order comedy MLC baby it
was like write one YouTube first came
out we were like oh my god like we can
actually post videos and people will see
them and dozens of people watched our
videos every week so we thought we were
superstars nice called Sierra Nevadas
sausage fest yeah sausage fest was we
actually were just having a party and we
had all of our equipment at our house
and we were like there's not a girl here
we should just have a beer called
sausage fest and then had the tank line
be bring on the dudes we just filmed our
actual party with not a single girl
there there was one girl and we're like
sorry you have to sit this one out
walks was like I was our ultimate dream
come true my character in workaholics I
was adam demamp the champ full-on maniac
people always weirded out when they meet
me in person because I'm not like that
peak level of crazy and they're like oh
I thought you'd be like much more of a
maniac I thought you'd be just like
demand and I'm like I would be dead that
man should have died like 30 times or at
least so concussed he couldn't put his
sentence together
Blake endures hate them hate them as
people as people I hate them as co-stars
great great guys but as human beings
they're monsters season 3 opener a
business trip launders gets invited to
go on this business trip with Alice our
boss to close this big account with the
Barracuda so we sort of tag along
because he's got this suite and we're
gonna party
happy business trip how do you beat you
here van we got fireworks pretty cool
right guys this is a note we sort of get
found out that we're there and Alice
comes and she's like we've got to shut
this down
but then the Barracudas there as well
and she's like wait you guys are doing
drugs I want to do it I'm here to party
and so then we all take acid and then it
just fully spirals out of control
Kyle knew a chick who ended up being our
director for basically everything we've
ever done that's where he really ran
with all the visuals stuff and we kind
of let him do what he does so like any
time that we don't out and go into like
their little drug world that's sort of
where he kind of stylistically made it
pretty awesome and incredible that God
we had him
show could've really sucked this perfect
was I'm so glad I did that movie because
I was on the fence cuz he was right
after I did workaholics luckily the
skirt was super funny
I asked Blake Tudors like what you guys
think of the script it's meaning
acapella singing and d'oeuvres ready it
was like it's really funny I think you
you'll crush it in this role and then
Blake was like yeah yeah I also think
it's good and and then came in my office
like late at night was we're working and
was like don't do this movie you're
gonna bury us no one will like
workaholics if you're in a singing movie
and you're an idiot
Blake because that movie came out and it
was it was so funny and people really
liked it and so I'm really glad I did it
my character bumper a little bit of an
egomaniac really just wants to be the
greatest but once again has that level
that base level of insecurity that
you're like this guy's compensating for
something I did a lot of vocal warm-ups
to prepare for the role it was always
double bubble chip a bubble gum yum-yum
aluminum linoleum aluminum linoleum
aluminum linoleum YUM
I did that for three months straight and
then shot the movie well we did this
riff off and pitch perfect
we're on paper I'm like how is this
gonna play but then they shot it all
cold war in a pool and there's light
sands at night and then it's just us
aggressively like singing to each other
which sounds really dumb and is really
dumb
but very very funny game over man was
like our little baby it's sort of like
diehard esque but instead of cool badass
John McClane you have three idiots I
play Alex with three exes and what's not
four he's like that friend that you have
that you love him to death but you can't
invite him over for a chill night only
the big events this Alex with three exes
get invited we got to keep him clear
because he's like we should chug this do
you think this would break on my head do
you think this would fit up my what's
that we had to do this scene where were
like strapped into an ironing board and
we swing across from two buildings and
we shot it on this green screen but
we're still hanging like 80 feet in the
air and then were dropped and so all day
long it was like we're on a very
aggressive roller coaster but instead of
like a comfortable roller coaster seat
you're like kind of hanging off this
clothes hanging board this little
coolest [ __ ] [ __ ] window
very weird bruises like I'm a dominatrix
or something cuz I'm had to wear this
harness so I had like aggressive bruises
right here
my girlfriend was you know trying to
like get a little Nikki and I'm like not
now this whole zone is off-limits Seth
Rogen and Evan Goldberg produced game
over man and we've been working on this
movie for years and they were shooting
neighbors when we first signed up to
have them produce our movie with us and
they were like well figure something out
for you and they they had us invent beer
pong I hope in a hundred years
that's just history like people are
going like actually no it's in this
movie the people that invented beer pong
are the guys from workaholics they
really wanted me to sink a ball and it
took me like it took two hours to shoot
that scene because for 45 minutes I'm
like I'll get it no just give me another
shot like we could just drop it off RAM
and I'm like no we're not we're getting
it in one I was a real monster about it
yeah my kid Danny wedding dates was like
that was the dream gig for me I fought
like tooth and nail to get it
I play Mike Stangl he's the older
brother but he's the one that doesn't
have his [ __ ] together the most and he's
definitely that archetype that I sort of
like find my way in of like a guy with
all this false bravado with a level of
insecurity at its base who really just
wants things to go his way but
throughout the movie things just start
spinning more and more out of control
and by the end he's full-on manic mode
at the beginning of the movie use you
see all these things going right like us
jumping on a trampoline and like I kiss
a girl that's on the roof and then we're
like shooting roman candles at each
other and it's kind of cute and fun and
we're doing like a fun dance and then
cut to the dad shows us the tape of what
actually happened and all those family
functions and I headbutt the girl and
she falls off and we're both bloody
we're shooting roman candles at each
other and we accidentally shoot it
inside this camper and it explodes
and I thought that was like a real cool
clever way to show like how we picture
ourselves and how we actually are the
intern was this cool Nancy Meyers movie
that I did so I played the character
Jason I sort of was the head of the
interns and DeNiro was one of the new
interns at the office and I kind of
showed him the ropes but then he showed
me how to live life as a real man I mean
I assume you talk to apologize till that
much he means to you well you know he
didn't talk to her what'd you do send
her a tweet
no of course not I like texted her a
billion times it was kind of fun for me
to play this character because he wasn't
so broad as like bumper was or Adam
Dammam and I kind of got to play a more
grounded character Robert didn't hear I
was like obviously he's like the man
right but he's really quiet if he thinks
you're funny
he'll like he like likes you and so
luckily he kind of thought I was funny
like snuck in there he wouldn't emit
sound when he would laugh he would just
jiggle which if you've ever seen Robert
DeNiro just jiggle the funniest thing in
the world cuz he does super DeNiro face
you'll say something funny he'll just
make the DeNiro face and go
Ratko the dictator son I think they paid
us like $11 that's it's not one of my
proudest moments
but I'll wear it with a badge of honor I
was I think I was like Generic party boy
number four and that's basically what
I've been playing the rest of my career
from what I can remember of that film
it doesn't hold up I'll say that when
the first meant was this movie I did me
Alexandra Daddario Shelley Hennig it
sort of starts out were at her
engagement party and you think that I'm
gonna be the one that's going to marry
the girl turns out I'm not and I'm
depressed and I like loved her and I've
liked since been friend-zoned it and I
go to the place that we had or like
first strings together and I fall into
this photo booth where we took photos
many years ago and it's sort of like the
zoltron machine in big and I go back in
time to see what I can do if I could
change something when I first met her
and then every time that I do something
I wake up the next day with those
consequences it was a really fun
character to play because I got to play
a bunch of different I got to play like
the sweet version of myself the maniac
version the douchey version the cool guy
version and that was my favorite version
because I got to be like like I got to
play this guy why do cool guys always
look like they have something in their
eyes have you ever noticed like they
could be totally normal and then they're
like hey what's up let's go to this
party and then cool guy does like well
saw I feel like my role as chief party
officer for Captain Morgan is maybe the
role I've been destined to play oh oh oh
so much more than that every one of my
roles have been a stepping stone to be
here because they've all been fun guy
party animals but now I know how to
handle myself and if you party with the
captain you've got to be able to handle
yourself cuz that guy a guy knows what's
up so we went and surprised this dude
Tyler on his 30th birthday party and
just sort of showed up at his house and
just sort of partied with this guy and
his friends and like I didn't know how
it was gonna go cuz this is a surprise
party and he it just blew his mind and
we had like a pretty great time every
role is like a little different and you
want to make it unique for that
character but then I feel like people
also want to see the thing that makes
you special as well come through that
character so I always try to bring some
uniqueness keep
grounded in some level that every person
can go like I know that guy
[Music]